the attack suspects background and how
we got into this country is raising
obvious questions about the role radical
Islam played in the attack and also
whether a visa program needs a major
overhaul here to discuss from Boston
Robert Spencer director of the website
jihad watch and from Portland Oregon
Harris afar author of the book
demystifying Islam tackling the tough
questions gentlemen it's good to see
both of you on a very difficult night
Harris let's start with you this man
apparently had some allegiance to Isis
notes found at the scene cried out
Allahu Akbar
truck attack after truck attack in
Europe and now coming to the United
States innocent slain how does the
average person watching the show tonight
not think given the pattern of behavior
that Islam does not have a major problem
with radicalization well I'll be remiss
Laura if I don't begin first and
foremost by expressing the Ahmadiyya
Muslim community's deepest condolences
to the victims of today's attack and
also expressing our deep gratitude to
the bravery of our law enforcement
officers who saved so many lives today
and since we are Muslims who believe in
that Messiah merciful America Dion who
came to revive the original teachings of
Islam we not only unreservedly condemn
these attacks and stand by innocent
civilians who we want to protect as well
but we also understand that there is
indeed a problem amongst certain groups
around around the world who are being
radicalized and the international leader
the halifa of the ahmadiyya muslim
community has indeed said that the West
should be very careful not to let all
people pour into their country that they
should be very vigilant about let about
who is allowed in because Isis
sympathizers and fanatics like them
might sneak into the country under the
guise of being refugees so the safety
and security of this country is
paramount what we say is that to have a
nuanced approach and instead of banning
wholesale people from certain countries
which was Pakistan was not even on in
that list and the most troublesome
country Saudi Arabia is not on the list
either
instead of instead of that have a
nuanced approach where we can get to the
room which is their ideology and
therefore I think you're right about
there's an ideological issue here but I
mean it's not a lot of room for nuance
we were talking about innocent lives you
probably wouldn't want this guy moving
into your neighborhood and and the
ahmadiya
Muslims are considered heretics you're
considered heretics by other Muslim
sects by the Salafist and so forth so
they take issue with your interpretation
correct of Islam which which I know is
an ongoing long-standing a debate within
Islam but Robert let's go to you this is
certainly you asked that question
right absolutely hold on guys so
community there 2% okay it's a small
percentage persecuted in Pakistan and
Indonesia right so there they are
persecuted but we have a radicalization
problem here in Mamaroneck with this
insane program of allowing people into
the country whose backgrounds frankly we
cannot check because now we can get
radicalized on the internet you can come
here and get radical oh yes American
citizens can as well but okay we already
have that problem we don't need more
problems that's my view Robert oh
absolutely you're absolutely right
look these programs all should have been
ended long ago and they need to be ended
immediately the fact is we have a hard
choice there is no reliable way to
distinguish between peaceful refugees
and people like this in New York City
murderer who are jihadis there is just
simply no way to tell and so we either
have to let in some harmful people or
keep out some harmless people and all
these years we've been told we're
racists and bigoted Islamophobes if we
want to keep out the harmful people
because that will mean keeping out some
of the harmless people well
unfortunately we have to make hard
choices here and this is it and
fact is that there is jihad recruitment
going on in mosques this guy has been in
the country seven years he certainly
went to mosques and so along with ending
these programs there has to be a
challenge to the Muslim community to
start teaching against these ideas of
jihad his mosque needs to be
investigated it needs to be shut down if
it's preaching jihad terror Harris do
you believe that mosques should be
surveilled given this radicalization
problem I know your your sect does not
have this issue this doesn't have this
problem but others do and it hurts all
of Islam to have this poison from within
it hurts the whole faith obviously it's
terrible
yeah yeah we're in a unique position
does the only Muslim community that's in
in 210 countries around the world with
one single leader and that leader has
been very clear the his holiness that he
has no problem with the government
official surveying our mosques because
we have nothing to hide
ultimately the solution that he has
offered forward is to root out there the
root of the problem which is both the
ideology and the funding traces of the
funding of Isis seemed to go to Saudi
Arabia yet we never even talked about
banning Saudi Arabians from entering the
country and